hello everyone and welcome to a fun
story from the 1966 chess Olympiad in
Havana Cuba the Soviets brought a very
very strong team board one was the world
champion at the time tigram petrosium
boards 2 was Boris plaski board three
was Mikhail Tao and board four was uh
the very strongly on each time even had
two reserves and the the night before
the first round Mikhail tal went out for
drinks as he usually does with uh he
went with um I believe he went with
coachnoy and he got a bit drunk and he
hit on someone's wife they beat him up
they hit him on the head with a bottle
and then he ended up in a hospital and
he had to stay in a hospital for a few
days so tal missed the first four rounds
of the uh of the Olympiad uh if some of
you were wondering why there are no
games of tal from the first four rounds
that's why there are no games and he won
uh the the first game when he got out of
the hospital he won a brilliant game in
round five and then he just continued
playing but yeah what a guy